- I call this video
August and I'll tell you why.
August fascinates me.
I grew up in the wine business
where you did a lot of business
with Europe and the late '90s,
early 2000s I was always
confused by August because
August was a time that
I completely got in the zone
because I knew
everyone was sleeping.
And what I mean by that is
everybody was on vacation.
In Europe, all my vendors
they were gone the whole month.
Ghost.
In the US a couple weeks here,
a couple weeks there and
it was really interesting.
I just really used
it as my time
to get ready for that
fourth quarter. Right?
People came back in September
and they were just rolling fast
for that prime time.
I was in retail.
For all you young hustlers out
there or old hustlers out there
August is the month.
This is the month where guys,
I'm taking plenty of time with
my family, this is when
people really slow it down.
Look for those out of office
replies 'cause they're
on the up during August.
And if you're watching this
video right now and if you want
it as bad as I hear you want it
and if this is your year and
if 2017's going to be your year
and if this is your moment and
if you're sick and tired and
it's your time then, my friends,
you need to understand that
these 30, is there 30 or 31?
These 31, I think, 31 days,
I hope that's right, in August,
these 31 days in August is
exactly when you triple down.
When you 4X, 5X
down on your hustle.
While everybody is
at the pool, drinking rosé
this is when you put
in the grinding hours.
And get ready for
your master plan.
August, my friends, is always,
always the month that sets the
tone for your future
for all the people that
are complaining or
disappointed at
where they're at.
Now, gonna flip
you a little bit.
August is also the month for all
those people that are content,
got bags under their eyes,
hustled all year, crushing it,
it's a very strategic month
to kind of go into
that rest period.
Get a little sun,
play a little tennis,
play in the pool
with your friends,
your girlfriend and your kids.
August is such an
interesting month for me.
You can play one of two ways
but it depends on where
your head's at right now.
(hip hop music)